y seguimos realizando entrevistas en el
marco de la feria internacional del
libro en la ciudad de bogotá y en esta
oportunidad me acompaña maría elvira
arango ella es periodista colombiana
tiene un programa de entrevistas y está
por supuesto presentando su libro mil
preguntas por elvira gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa un gusto
estar aquí para mí es un placer para mí
también es un placer y también es un
reto entrevistarte a ti maría elvira con
tanta gente que hace entrevistado más de
mil preguntas seguramente has hecho aquí
le quiero preguntar entonces por eso
realmente de qué se trata este libro de
qué va este libro son 23 entrevistas y
el título bueno como anillo al dedo uno
siempre tiene mil preguntas para hacerle
a un entrevistado cierto uno y si tengo
mil preguntas para ti son 23 personajes
de la vida actual porque no son
solamente colombianos que tienen algo
para decir que me parece que tienen algo
interesante que contar y logramos en la
entrevista que hubiera química que
hubiera empatía eso cuando uno hace
entrevistas
cuál es el reto cuál fue el reto más más
importante de plasmar todas esas
entrevistas en el libro y me imagino
también elegir cuáles fueron las
entrevistas que pusiste en este libro
bueno las escogimos por eso porque
tenían algo especial para contar nos
salimos un poco del tema político como
para sacudir uno y estamos en elecciones
y entonces qué delicia algo que tenga
hay personajes del bueno de la cultura
hay personajes bueno ingrid betancourt
por ejemplo de digamos de la consultura
no necesariamente de la coyuntura
gente que tiene alguna historia
interesante que contar y creo que hay de
todo un poquito te hace llorar te hace
reír y bueno son entrevistas que se le
es muy muy sabroso como decimos en
colombia maría elvira también le quiero
preguntar cuál fue esa entrevista que
más le costó para hacer este vídeo
siempre es difícil es como la película
preferida de la revista preferida a mí
lo que me pasa cuando con las
entrevistas que me cuestan trabajo es
con las que yo me siento más que me
desmoronó por ejemplo las que me hacen
llorar cuando la es la historia que me
están contando es tan dura de esas
historias que uno oye del conflicto por
ejemplo o de la violencia que realmente
me impactan y me y me sorprende estar
frente a una persona que tuvo el coraje
y el valor de sobreponerse a ese dolor
oa esa situación esas son las que más
trabajo me cuestan claro los personajes
difíciles alguna vez me dijo un jefe que
tuve yo que no este no me pasa los
teléfonos que éste no quiere que este
mes insista algún momento le van a decir
que sí de manera que la dificultad no es
tanto por
a la altura del personaje sino por la
historia que tienen para contar así es
muy débil y también pues obviamente
estamos en el mismo premio también
entrevistó personas de bien pues yo soy
periodista y a veces es difícil conectar
con este personaje generar la confianza
y por más abierto que uno esté también
uno siente muchas veces una barrera con
este personaje entonces cómo hacer para
romper esa barrera por más bacano de
gajo que sea uno pues yo creo que ese es
el ss el alma que yo creo que tiene mil
preguntas porque por más somos
periodistas y por más de que uno trate
de hacerlo lo más amable
amigable pues hay una grabadora hay una
cámara y luces no la gente se intimida
es si uno logra pasar por encima de eso
yo creo que hay uno está por lo menos ya
más cerca de hacer una entrevista por lo
menos real y como lo dices mayoría
también uno puede hablar con un
personaje fuera de cámaras y todo fluye
muy bien y se prende la cámara y es como
una cartón a mí a estridencias pero
estamos en el mismo contexto que hace un
segundo pero claro si intimidan las
cosas
algo que decía en el prólogo del libro
era el arte escuchar también obviamente
yo soy músico verde por ejemplo y marca
la que también decía que lo más
importante una entrevista desea escuchar
al entrevistado cómo es ese arte
yo no sé si habéis es difícil por
supuesto es difícil y a veces los
periodistas como que van con actitud de
que están esperando que les digan algo
que quieren que yo o detrás de la
noticia de repente si uno va con la
intención más bien de la actitud abierta
de escuchar lo que esa persona tiene
para decir porque esa persona que lo
motiva que lo asusta que lo hace llorar
que le da miedo o que chivas le voy a
sacar pero con cariñito y con cuidadito
de repente se consigue me parece que ese
es el manera el libro tiene como varios
capítulos no vamos a por lo menos tratar
de de hablar por encimita para que para
la gente evidentemente compre el libro y
lo pueda leer porque más está muy rico
de la vida y sus dolores que podemos
encontrar en este segmento si a mí me
parece que la historia de piedad bonnett
es además es la primera y está muy bien
ahí porque uno empieza es el libro y te
pones a llorar que se subió se suicidó
tiene uno de los libros más bellos que
se ha publicado sólo vio lo que no tiene
nombre yo soy mamá
siempre tratándose como periodista de
ponerme de ser empática con mi
entrevistado y yo creo que esos son los
casos en donde la palabra queda muy
chiquita no hay un dolor que describa y
por más que uno intente entender lo que
esa persona está viviendo saber lo que
significa que un hijo de uno se haya
suicidado
me parece conmovedora me parece
bello además porque está bellamente
narrado ella es una poetisa increíble
que admiro entonces yo creo que ahí hay
les arranca da que te llega el corazón y
es muy delicado también hablar con una
persona que ha pasado por un dolor
también tan grande y pues el manejo que
uno no tiene que dar esa entrevista para
que la persona se sienta cómoda y no
incomodar al entrevistado porque también
es un arte no si presionar en lo que no
quiere yo siento que también un poco
periodista a veces creo que yo evito
hacerlo no pero no como indagar y
decirle más allá de lo que el invitado
quiera decir no yo siento que también
tiene como respetar ese espacio de la
persona que simplemente no le quiere
decir no porque una periodista te tiene
que decir lo que tú quieres así es como
la la magia de una entrevista y cuando
una persona te está abriendo el corazón
imagínate el cuidado que tienes que
tener el mundo todos los exactos de la
vida y las pasiones que pasiones podemos
encontrar en mil preguntas las pasiones
hay un personaje que además adoro que se
llama andrés parra es un gran actor es
decir claro claro el lado de andrés que
nadie conocía adicto a la comida
como logró superar una persona que comía
convulsión comprensivamente sin parar
llegaba a las 2 de la mañana y se comía
cuatro hamburguesas una pizza bowl ya se
acostaba se levantaba y se comió
calentado y lograr que andrés contara
una parte tan angustiosa de su vida
cuando la gente siempre ve como la parte
exitosa porque es un actor y yo creo que
es muy valioso esa entrevista que logró
como contarnos y cómo superó eso no
porque yo hoy en día uno lo ve como un
atleta no se puede
son historias que inspiran los narcos
diferencia por supuesto estamos en un
país como colombia pero yo le quiero
preguntar si es herencia de los narcos
en mil preguntas es la que podemos
encontrar nos separa nuestro dice
internacional una serie más de netflix
como está contada experiencia de los
narcos en mi cuerpo y la aproximación
son en este caso tres personajes y la
hija de carlos lehder el hijo de pablo
escobar y la viuda de pablo escobar y yo
lo que quise saber cómo son esas como
vive uno con este apellido en el caso de
mónica líder con su papá en la cárcel
toda su vida como usted es o no llamarse
1 mónica líder en este país eso es como
salió uno soy un letrero y ni se diga de
la familia de pablo escobar que aunque
se cambiaron el nombre pues tuvieron que
rehacer su vida en argentina y todavía
hoy 30 años después
el país les sigue cobrando a ellos los
crímenes de su padre no han podido así
hayan pedido perdón seguir puede hacer
una vida tranquila no ellos cargan esa
cruz por ser familiares de pablo escobar
y a mí me interesaba mucho saber cómo se
vive siendo el hijo del narco más grande
y más poderoso del mundo qué fácil es
señalar pero también qué difícil es
ponerse en los zapatos de esa persona
así o sea
como en el libro yo creo que maría
elvira a la gente puede decir y entender
un poco más y tener más sensibilidad es
así esa sensibilidad que creo que hemos
perdido muchos de nosotros o sea además
no hay tiempo no si estás haciendo una
entrevista para televisión o para radios
y la televisión o la ventaja de aquí es
que por lo menos puedes conocer pues el
carácter de la persona cuáles son sus
motivaciones y de repente ahí te puedes
hacer una imagen distinta a la que
tenías o no estás como en la libertad
pero tienes más argumentos por lo menos
me encanta eso también de conocer a las
personas porque yo también el trato eso
no es como más allá del personaje pues
estamos somos seres humanos y todos
luego tomamos café por la mañana o un té
si no le gusta pero comemos respirábamos
otra tenemos los mismos dolores nos
enfermamos y eso es yo creo que también
muy rico lograr eso y yo siento que los
entrevistados son son agradecidos son
agradecidos por eso maría elvira
en el libro podemos encontrar también
tienes un programa para la revista
internacional un programa muy famoso
todos los domingos en canal acaba muy
reconocido en colombia de entrevistas no
de crónicas super super rica jamás como
cómo se cuentan podemos ver esas mismas
crónicas que has hecho esas entrevistas
aquí en el libro son completamente
diferentes o simplemente no tenemos algo
más corto y aquí como algo más ampliado
no ni siquiera es por eso ni siquiera es
por lo largo lo corto sino personajes
que sí han sido protagonistas de
informantes que me causaron cualquier
cualquier algún sentimiento sobre
sorpresa hoy a mí me parece que si uno
hace una entrevista y no pasa nada esa
entrevista no sirve por lo menos que te
emocione que te aburra que te entristece
escalaban a llorar que la hora de sal
entonces están escritas para prensa que
si es un formato distinto y además
tienen un un ritmo muy muy particular
por ser entrevistas para prensa han
salido de los personajes sin informantes
y en otras entrevistas que hice alguna
vez en bocas en la revista del tiempo
pero aquí están de otra manera y
terminamos con una guerra y sus heridas
wow hablar de un conflicto tan largo
como el colombiano 50 años por ahí y las
heridas
ya estamos padeciendo tengo yo que
espera que te interrumpa pero yo que no
soy colombiano llega a este país hace
siete años ya y medio y todavía hay
rastros de la guerra de violencia en la
sociedad qué triste si yo yo yo creo que
clara rojas
que las amistades con su hijo emmanuel
que nadie había hablado con él como cómo
es ese niño
emanuel se volvió como parte del
conflicto colombiano como el símbolo de
la
cruda crueldad máxima porque un niño que
una mujer que pare un bebé en la selva
que se lo quitan de milagro lo recuperó
la historia declara y emanuel me parece
que es una historia de guerra como pocas
en el mundo y la de ingrid que esa indio
que está ahí era una ingrid que tenía la
piel en carne viva porque se estaba
hasta ahora esperando de semejante
secuestro y santrich que me llamaba
mucho la atención siempre pensé será que
sean príncipe
y entonces la pregunta es
cuando yo le pedí la entrevista yo lo
que quería saber era si él me veía o no
y ella le pregunte usted que dice no una
sombra pero nunca
nunca hubiese pero bueno es un personaje
emblemático de nuestra de nuestros años
de guerra de lo que hemos sufrido en
colombia ese sería crees que que pronto
podrán sanar todavía faltarán 50 años
más para sanar hasta entonces la
pregunta evidentemente es de estar la
quisiéramos saber lo hiciéramos que
fuera mañana pero pero por lo que ha
conversado con tanta gente que ha
conversado víctima del conflicto
victimarios también en su momento de
este conflicto
solamente una parte no porque las farc
es una cosa y todavía hay muchas muchas
guerrillas activas en el país están las
disidencias ahora
qué puede pasar no sé o yo creo que es
trabajos como éste como los que hacemos
todos los días
visibilizando este país a la gente que
hace este país de un lado o del otro con
unas ideas o con las otras eso ayuda a
sanar las heridas no contando los
dolores y contando las realidades que
viven los colombianos así que yo creo
que bueno en algo una curita una ayudita
para algo así es respetarnos a
encontrarnos ver ver los puntos en común
en vez de la diferencia porque yo creo
que el mundo también ya está muy lleno
de odio de indiferencia como para
nosotros también a seguir así así que la
invitación es a eso a encontrar o no
maría elvira gracias gracias de verdad
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de francés y 4 un placer haber
conversado contigo esperemos que en
algún momento lo podremos encontrar y
pues nada ustedes también muchísimas
gracias por seguirnos por estar un día
más con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 continúe porque hay mucho más
para ver aquí en nuestro caso